with the great financial impact that the
kobe pandemic will have had
on well pretty much all of the members
of nato
it is certainly possible that the
spending increases will be either halted
or even perhaps reversed in some cases
what would
america's opinion be if that were to
happen
we can't afford to let a health crisis
become a security crisis
and i think if we are going to
look at what our adversaries are doing
like russia a rising china
they're not stopping their malign hybrid
attacks
they're not stopping the belt and road
initiative they're not
in any way lessening their defense capab
capabilities if president trump were to
win the election
next month and have another four years
in office what
would that term look like for nato
would he embrace the alliance more than
he did in his first term do you think
i think that he has come
to the realization because he's
asked our allies to do more and he sees
that they are stepping up
that nato is very valuable it's a
valuable
and essential transatlantic alliance
both for our european allies but also
for the united states we've got to
stand together and understand the
importance of security
is what has kept our economy strong
what role do you think there is if any
for nato
in countering any perceived
chinese advance well i think that we
have to be clear-eyed about what china
is doing
they are taking over
port after port after port including in
europe
the belton road initiative is one
more area where we're seeing china use
economic power
for taking assets
when predatory loans cannot be repaid
and we consider that malign activity
we don't want china to be an adversary
but we must prepare for what we are
seeing
if you look at and i'm only using your
three and a half years
in in the post um because i'm talking to
you specifically but if you look at
russia's actions over the last three and
a half years they they are still in
ukraine they are still in crimea
moscow-backed mercenaries are acting
in parts of central and north africa and
syria they are they have their fingers
in
involvement in belarus and elsewhere
around the world i mean
despite the actions of nato and
european and american
governments it hasn't really done much
to stop russia has it
russia would have been more aggressive
had we not taken that stand after crimea
we know that russia is trying to divide
us
in with many different areas
of aggression and i think we are making
a difference and i think
the deterrence that we are producing
is the signal to russia that
we would like for them to become a
legitimate partner we would like to
trade with russia we would like to have
relationships
but they have to change their behavior
to achieve that